[Music]
when you need to quickly deploy and
scale your workloads on a global cloud
infrastructure you need a cloud that's
designed for your data AI ready and
secured to the core with data centers in
19 countries and on six continents our
network is built for local access low
latency and high security all while
meeting the most stringent data
sovereignty and compliance regulations
IBM clouds network architecture
comprises three separate layers of
network traffic which offers unmatched
speed and security from and between our
data centers choose a data set are close
by to deploy high-performance workloads
on any type of cloud public private and
hybrid and move data among them quickly
plus our comprehensive platform as a
service offerings include Watson AI
machine learning services containers and
blockchain migrator extend your VMware
and s ap workloads into the cloud in a
self-managed environment or with the
full service support of our cloud
experts the era of digital
transformation needs a cloud that
provides performance control and
scalability a cloud that's designed for
your data AI ready and secure to the
core IBM cloud is the cloud for business
yours
[Music]
you